here we go and we back again
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
your favorite podcast
[Music]
all right y'all be back again uh we're
gonna have a little super bowl recap
um i have an interview with my buddy
nick dune who's
coming out in this movie the right one
so yeah so we got a little bit of solo a
little bit of interview
a little bit of super bowl talk tell you
what i did
and then we'll just go right into the
interview and then that'll be that and
then i'll see you next week right and
make sure you remember i always
stream on air griffin gaming every day
so welcome to real favorite films
all right reference griffin is back um
welcome super bowl edition what a game
right well it actually wasn't even a
good game
if if you don't know that tom brady's
the goat at this point
if you've doubted him if you felt like
he wasn't
the one you didn't like him you just
hate him you think he wasn't talented
enough you think he wasn't skilled
enough you think whatever you think
other people are
you think other people got better game
to him whatever you want to say the dude
got
seven super bowls seven he's been to ten
he's won
seven he's just a leader he's inspiring
you know he's 43 years old playing at
the hardest sport
to play the most physically challenging
sport in american sports and he's doing
it
succeeding led another group of men to
the super bowl and they won
so it is what it is there's nothing else
to be said tom brady is the best
okay so there goes that the game wasn't
even i mean patrick mahomes
he just looked shook i think he was
injured i think that
foot was hurting him the two offensive
tackles that weren't playing
the the the calls like compared to the
other game that was like they were it
was like a lot of rough play going on in
that green bay game they were letting
them pull and you know all the things
they were letting them do
none of that was going on in the super
bowl i thought it was a really weirdly
called
game but you know it is what it is
not to say that took anything away i
mean they beat the [__] out of them so
there's no
there's no turning back from that no
matter what
there's no excuses they didn't they just
were not
ready to play so good for tom brady good
for gronkowski
coming back again and catching
touchdowns i mean
they just those guys look like they were
just having a good time and they'll
probably come back again next year
i mean the dude's on his way you know
he's going to take this tb12 brand and
make it
into just a billion dollar business now
even more so now like i was saying last
week because now he's like hey i'm 43
i won the super bowl because of tb12 you
know and then that's what everybody's
going to be like think of all the dudes
right now in their 40s
late 30s even 50s who were like damn i
got to get on that program that tom
brady's on so i could be
you know more athletic and more
successful at what i'm doing so
it really was amazing um the whole thing
is amazing going to a new team
during covid not being able to practice
a lot
you know learning a new system changing
the culture
everything that he did kudos to him tom
brady's the best
so i had um i don't know what you guys
did you know they were they were
worried about the super spreader you
know events parties um i didn't have a
party
i didn't um but i did invite two of my
buddies over
because my buddy vinnie and he had
brought his cousin rumson who
was been bragging about these ribs
you know for months he's like i gotta
make the best ribs of me so i said well
bring your soggy ass ribs over because
he makes these like
he's he likes some wet so he teased them
about his old soggy ribs
they were delicious shout out to him i
had some good ass ribs
rachel made some spinach dip from
scratch didn't even know she could do
that
it was delicious that was great so um
you know and then they came over and you
know we
you know i didn't want to have a lot of
people over even two is too much really
in just
this day and age and uh i didn't really
post about it i didn't i didn't take we
didn't take a lot of pictures or nothing
like that because
not everything you do needs to be on the
internet
you know not everything you don't have
to share everything about your life on
the internet
and what's happening right now is y'all
got to be cautious because
you know you're at some party
you could be at some party you put it on
instagram oh look i'm at a party
then you go to work whatever your job
might be and they might be like
uh yeah um you're not being safe
so we have to let you go
it happens happened to my friend my
friend
rachel friend of my girlfriends she um
you know was gonna be in a movie had a
little part
they saw her instagram she had a party
no masks they were like nah
so it is what it is i mean optics are
important too
even if you don't agree with like even
if you think things are going too far
you think
people are being like too cautious like
too scary whatever you might
feel about it it is what it is this is
the world we live in
so people you know it's like when you go
to the airport you gotta take your shoes
off it's ridiculous to me
all that dog and pony show stuff that
you have to do
at when you go to the airport is so
people feel safe even if
even if they're not actually safe but
you know with the masks you know it is
what it is
you need to wear your mask so people
feel safe people need to know that
you're being safe
so they can feel safe when they're
around you it's a whole ripple domino
effect but anyways
had a small gathering um two friends
you know and it was fun you know it was
uh it was it was a lot of fun
just to be around people and sharing a
meal
really you know we all made something
and came together so
that was uh pretty cool and then we
watched the game which was
and we had fun making jokes but it was
boring i thought the game was boring
you know there wasn't too much
excitement uh and then and then you know
[__] bucks one but i will say this uh
you know so news new segment i'm going
to be doing along with real world advice
from a grown ass man which will be back
next week
new segment bitchin with griffin people
call this so let's [__] about these
these uh super bowl commercials i
thought some of them were good i thought
the matthew mcconaughey commercial
i thought i thought that one was uh
you know i thought that one was pretty
good that's pretty funny where he was
like
you know he was like flat you know he
needed the 3d
i thought that was funny i thought the
will ferrell i mean just will ferrell is
just always funny
you know what i mean you know so it's
like there's nothing really to there's
something really to say about that
you know then they had a lot of you know
weird commercials
a lot of like pseudo-inspiring
commercials you know we kind of do the
you know
the uplifting stuff because that's the
day and age we live in
sometimes i feel like i i hate them
i hate when they do like an uplifting
commercial but then it's like for beer
you know i remember guinness had a
commercial like that where it was like
you know it it's like all these dudes in
wheelchairs and they're playing
basketball and they're you know you're
like oh man this is great and they're
like and they drink guinness it's like
what what does that have to do with
these dudes in a wheelchair
you know what i mean like it's like i
stopped piggybacking some
some like that feeling we get when we
watch people overcoming something
you know they had all i hate when it's
for a product
to me it's like get out of here with
that
you know the sesame street that was old
school sesame street
you know i saw uh that's from my
childhood
you know thought that was funny and then
you saw like i just
listen state farm the state farm
commercials are funny
shout out to my boy kevin the new jake
from state farm he was funny
my favorite was drake from state farm i
just thought
drake is funny i want to play his dad on
the sitcom if you ever go to the tv
y'all be going to sit in the petition
for me to do that but
i'm sick of the state farm commercials
because aaron rodgers they
state farm wants aaron rodgers to make
the super bowl so
bad if it was aaron rodgers vs patrick
mahomes
oh my god that would have been that
state farm would have just been crazy
they would have went crazy with all the
ads and commercials but i'm sick of
those get them out of there
aaron rodgers lost get him out okay i
don't see him anymore in it with these
commercials
again like toyota it's like the girl got
no legs
what did what i got to do with toyota
you know what i mean
just the whole thing is the whole
thing's bananas
but the one that pissed me off the most
is this
oatly milk you want to talk about
somebody having a yes man around them
okay
this dude got a lot of yes men around
him
because he was the commercial and i
think he did it on purpose because he
knew everybody would hate it
dude he's singing like what was the
board meeting for this where he was like
i got an idea
let's pay a million dollars for a
commercial but
i'm gonna be the commercial i'm gonna
sing
and do the jingle as the president of
the company what is everybody gonna say
you know they're gonna be like oh yeah
sir oh my god oh bro yeah
oh oh great idea oh my god this is the
best
yes wow we all should have thought of
that so get out of here man
garbanzo beans man places like that
should hire me
i need to be like you know how a lot of
people got yes men around them
you need me i'm gonna come in as the no
man nah i don't think you should do that
that'll be what i do you that's why you
hire me and i i go
nope anytime you want to do something
nope don't do that
nope i'm the nope man
nope man nope man that's what i want to
be
so every week i'll try to [__] about
something since that's my brand
but yeah so the commercials were just
weird uh you know but
again it wasn't enough i mean this is
different because i go to vegas every i
use
i go to vegas every year for the super
bowl it's the fun thing i
like to go with my buddy jeff and we do
these prop bets every year
you know we'll bet on like who's who did
the the coin toss to
you know all that stuff i love betting
on that stuff you just five ten dollars
on this stuff you have like 20 of them
in your hand
you know it's great this first time i
didn't haven't gone in like 20 years
so you know it is what it is um
you know what are you supposed to do you
know what i mean i just felt
i wanted to be at home i felt like i
don't want to deal with the travel and
going out and
right now i got some gigs coming up
because they're that i already had
booked from like
seven eight months ago and i'm just
nervous about it and i got
they're asking me to do some other gigs
like arizona
you know that kind of stuff and i'm like
ah do i want to do it so
i got to get up some courage and get
back out there i haven't been on a plane
in over a year and i just been used to
being a homebody you know so but anyways
i don't want to keep you guys much
longer with me talking my yippy app
real world advice from a grown mass man
coming next week so make sure you check
out my instagram follow me on instagram
eric griffin because i usually put the
question up there then i get the
questions from instagram right there
so uh and then again i game on air
griffin gaming every day on twitch so
check me out there
other stuff come coming in the gaming
world so i'm excited about that
but anyways now um this is uh my buddy
nick thune
he was in a movie called the right one
and he's out in vancouver right now
shooting a movie so we got on uh
we got on the internet call and i just
interviewed him and it's good catching
up with somebody that i haven't talked
to
in a while and he talks talks a little
bit about the movie and his life and uh
you know we just get into like shop top
shop shop talk as comics often do so
first i'll play the trailer from the
movie and then i'll get into the
interview with nick
and once again thanks for watching
griffin with griffin
hi sarah i am expecting to see some
pages by the end of the week you hear me
uh yeah i know i know i am just working
here
are you fake typing no
shall we discuss your deadline no
anything but that god i wish i could
return that stupid advance
not stupid it's amazing especially
considering the fact that nobody reads
that anymore
what about right now what if we just
lived right now what's this guy
i don't know looks like austin powers up
chimney sweep
[Music]
excuse me weren't you at the wanky
gallery in fremont
i truly think you have me mistaken for
somebody else
who the hell are you
what's this guy's name anyway you know
what i don't know
i brought you here for a reason i got a
feeling about you
you're mistaking crazy for interesting
you're a complete original
he's not one person he's like many
different people
what is that he is the company's
top sales performer for three straight
years
[Music]
that the intelligence breaking about
eight different dress code policies
is he ever himself have i actually even
met the guy
i need to know who i'm with
[Music]
i'm so confused like who have i been
hanging out with this whole time
i'm ready today
i was kind of in a funk i couldn't
access my creativity
and then i met you and that all went
away
if you reduce the world down we're all
just one big organism
what we do has an effect on others
who are you
you know i am a good friend and friends
tell each other the truth even when it
sucks
yeah well this lunch sucks the food is
very good but the food is very this
sucks
hey everybody welcome to riverin with
griffin and we have one of the stars
of the new movie the right one and one
of my longtime friends
uh fellow comedian mr nixon nick we've
had technical difficulties but we're
here now
welcome to the podcast and thanks for
being here and we just saw the trailer
um but let's talk about the movie then
yeah then we'll catch up and like be
you know i want to find out how you're
doing what you've been doing and all
that kind of great stuff in these crazy
times but
welcome yeah yeah how are you doing it's
an honor to be here
um i want to thank everybody that made
this possible i know that
there was like 10 people involved on
emails and
you know isn't it funny how agents and
managers and publicists they want to
feel
so important that they want to be you
know it's like i was saying from the
beginning
do i have i remember that i had your
number i wasn't sure if i had it or you
changed your number
but i'm going through them and i just
thought to myself look at my phone nick
there it is then i hit you hey man
you know it's so much easier like this
but you know we pay them so much of our
money that we
they have to do something right and then
i get that text from you and it says hey
do you want to
update your you know contact information
eric's got a new picture
so so now i see your new picture and
i've got and you're
you're all updated in my phone it's just
it really brought us together
yeah yeah it's like it's brought us
together over so much time you know it's
funny you say that it's like it's funny
how like i always say like
working comedians are like working at
like a really
big super walmart you know and so like
maybe you're over in produce and i'm
over in like
mechanical and we see each other in the
break room and we work together sort of
but it's like we still like you know
when it comes to like what are you doing
in your personal life and all that kind
of stuff we may not necessarily know but
it's it's amazing how many like of these
like sort of
like relationships that we have because
of comedy that you know we
we probably should do better at but it's
like man there's so many of them and you
know we live in so many different places
it's hard to it's hard to keep up
i mean it's like it's like hey do you
know eric and mechanics it's like i mean
yeah we've walked by each other in the
green room a couple times
you know i mean um we parked next to
each other last week and that was a fun
walk i know that you might you might say
like hey how you doing oh it's good to
see you what's going on in produce
everything's great
cool man big e yeah yeah yeah yeah we
yeah we got those like work nicknames
[Laughter]
all right here comes nick now oh it's
knick-knack paddy wack what's going on
buddy
um but let me see so the right one uh
listen i saw the trailer i started
watching some of the movies i got they
sent me a thing and i started watching
some of it last night i got to say man
this is like you know
it's weird because you're a leading man
in this movie but then you're also doing
like
like so many different types of versions
of yourself
um you know how was that i mean you know
we saw that
you know everybody just saw the trailer
and it's like i say you're playing so
many different characters
and i thought that myself i saw i was
like oh man oh nick's the leading man in
this good for him but then i was like oh
wait a minute
he's doing character he's also he's also
the weirdo in the movie he's the friend
of the movie he's like so what was what
tell us about this movie like
what's your experience and what do you
think about it yeah i think it was like
originally written for
somebody that we're friend i probably
shouldn't say who but somebody who is
really capable of doing
accents all right and and and like
really capable of kind of stepping into
this weirdness of like you know and i
got
you know they passed on it luckily so
they went to the next guy in line which
is
obviously me um and who knows how many
how he knows how many guys were in line
before me but when they got to me
i i called the director i said listen i
love the script i mean i just i don't
want to like
promise something that i can't deliver i
can't do
accents like they scare me i turn down
auditions with like southern accents in
this
right right he said oh no we'll we'll
we'll tune the movie up to you and what
your strengths are and then we get there
day one and he's like all right do an
accent i'm like what
no we had a full phone conversation i
gave you an
out i did everything they were like
listen we wanted russell brand
[Laughter]
so yeah do that and i was like listen
i'll do my version
which is going to be a guy that doesn't
quite know how to do accents but he's
fully committed
yeah and you know like it was really
this this role was fun because it
you know i know that you you you've done
stuff before where
you know you're being funny and when you
when you do the things where
you're supposed to be dramatic it's like
you really have to
commit to fail you know like a lot of
the times it felt like i was failing but
then they're like we got it
you know and it had to feel that way
because i had to let go of any control
to be cool or
to try and be funny it had to had to be
real i know exactly what you mean
actually because it's like when i was
doing i'm dying up here and it was like
this
you know this dramatic role that i
didn't realize how dramatic it was
and what does that really mean to comics
it just means
don't push to be funny uh just rely on
your natural
instincts of whatever in in this moment
but you know
we're so used to like having instant
gratification of like if i don't do
something to make
the ether laugh i'm not being funny and
it's it's
it's like i actually found doing drama
easier than comedy
you know yeah it's especially if it's
you know when the comedy's written out
like a
um like a multi-cam where you're on a
stage and there's an audience i have a
hard time with that because
you know if they're not going to allow
me to do my own timing and kind of bring
in my thing like
i know how to sell a joke that's you
know like not mine but
i when it's something like this and you
and the comedy comes out of the
character
that's what i love that the what you
just said about the stand-up like i
you know we're so used to the here's
here's how i picture the audience when
i'm performing
when they laugh they're yelling we like
you yeah this is good
keep doing what you're doing and i'm
saying cool here comes more of it
they're like
yep right on par with what you did
before keep it up you know
like constant dialogue of them affirming
you
and on set i mean if you get a key grip
to laugh
you know and you might have to do a
reshoot you might have to read through
another thing
that guy's fired yeah
yeah yeah you know it's funny you say
that i know i just remember working on
an audition with a buddy of mine
and he you know he was like the the
charac he wasn't
the star of this scene you know and he's
you know he's doing all this stuff and i
said to him
i i said to him hey man you're not the
funny in this the funny is
you being completely normal and this
star is reacting in this situation
like so much of it is like reaction and
what's happening in the moment but as a
performer you think
you know we have this tendency to be
like no it's it's what i'm
doing right now and then when you can
get comfortable just being who you are
in a scene
then then if you're funny you're going
to be funny and it's just going to play
and it's it's different energy
obviously right yeah the acting really
comes between your lines
for me it's it's like
it's that listening that that's when
you're acting
you because you're you're hearing what
they're saying and you're taking it in
as that character and you're formulating
the response which you already have read
and learned
but now you have to say it in a way that
seems like it's just
natural you know and it's so so like you
can't do that if you're not
fully acting in between your lines and
like
just listening to them you know like i
that's my big that was my biggest
problem in the beginning it's like i'm
just waiting to talk
it's like yeah get your line okay cool
and now i know
i know i mean that's just the nature of
being like a selfish artist really you
know that's just what we are we're just
like these like
yeah you know selfish attention monsters
in um
you know when we're doing stand-up
you know yeah you know i often think
about you know i remember one time
this comic came up to me and like i was
doing it
because i used you as a reference um
because he plays the guitar on stage
this particular comic you know
and i was doing a joke that it was
similar to a friend of his
joke or whatever right i've never you
know it's not to me it wasn't the same
we just had the same reference you know
and he you know and i said to him well
what if i said you're doing what nick
thune does
because uh you know you're playing a
guitar on stage because that's the only
that's the only you know that's the
similarity it's just similar to the
other thing
you know so it's like what do you like
you know because
when i when i wa do do you consider
yourself a mainstream comic or do you
even
like those kinds of distinctions you
know it's like being like an alternative
comic versus like a you know
or political comic versus like do you
even have those kind of distinctions or
how would you even
classify yourself when it's when it
comes to like yeah you know
because it's kind of hard i feel like
this role i think i feel like this role
really lends itself to even how you do
comedy you know what i mean like
yeah because you're just you're putting
on a performance even when you're on
stage within
every word every joke that you do and
how you do it and how you present it so
how do you if that question even makes
sense well i know
it does actually and if i like really
quickly i want to like label what i see
your comedy as because
you know like i here's how i view comedy
like you get on stage
and it's funny it's just funny you're
funny you're taught the way you talk the
way you respond
your thought process and so like that's
mainstream to me because that's an
authentic version of you
that's that i'm seeing so anybody can
grasp that
now the references might be geared more
towards
20 somethings or you know whatever
depending on who you're going to but
the beginning of my career when i was um
just
getting up at places and you know
becoming a regular at the improv
i was going up the lap factory at eight
and going up at ucb and some weird show
at 10
and i was doing the same set and that to
me felt like okay this is like
mainstream because i can do it across
platforms and i'm still it's working
you know it's working at the laugh
factory it's working here and if i give
it that if i can do it across the board
like that
and then it was the same thing of like
doing leno and then doing conan you know
where it was like okay if i can do both
of these
but i don't know if my comedy is meant
for
huge audiences i love where it's at i i
love like
i love going to a city and having a good
amount of people that really are
invested in seeing me
and i can give them i just want to
perform like to those people
it's so fun you know we've been doing it
long enough now that we can look at
ourselves now and go
okay so i didn't become kevin hart
you know what i mean yeah you know so
even if that was my intention when i
first started is i want to play and
do with this and that okay so it doesn't
happen like that and then you just go
well who is my audience and it's like i
guess as a comic you
you know as an entertainer you go i like
my audience
you know i like these this amount of
people when i go to a show and i know
because i guess i know what you're
saying because i feel like for me it's
like i'd rather have a room full of 50
people that love me
than a thousand people where like 800 of
them are like well
who's this guy or i don't know i get
this or
you know but even if they just laugh
like hahaha i guess we're laughing
because everybody's laughing you know
so i get what you're saying yeah a
nietzsche i said
at one point i was telling my audience i
go here's how you can tell my audience
there's a lot of guys that look kind of
like me and a lot of girls that look
confused as to where they are
like girlfriends like girlfriends that
they brought with them like you know and
um i every time i have a new opener and
i try and keep like you know i try and
kind of keep the same
people because i love who i'm around
dictates my
my attitude and my performance and and
they're always just like wow this
audience they're so nice they're so kind
and kind of
you know and that's what i love and i
toured with this musician
who plays like 500 seats you know and he
just does that's probably his peak
and he's like i don't want any more and
i don't want any less
if i i just want to keep this because
it's enjoyable
it's nice i the room feels good
you know like if that's how i feel every
time i perform then
great and if i'm surviving great yeah
man i know what you're saying
you know i know i know exactly what
you're saying it's you know
even though even though it's like i do
this podcast you know and it's like
you know it's like damn do i want my
podcast to be as big as rogan's podcast
or
you know you know what i mean like is
that what you measure yourself on
every time you do anything it's like
who's doing it on a grander scale
is that what i'm trying to achieve and
there is a part of you that
is trying to achieve that but it's about
just being comfortable with like
who you are and how you get to that
point and so that's why i realize it's
like oh okay so i'm at this point this
might not be what
a a greater audience wants
but i've found the audience that does
want it and that feels
comfortable so when you when you started
when you started doing stand-up did you
always did you envision yourself always
being an
actor was it an actor first stand up
second or was it like just
you always had a mind of doing both
i it was stand up first and then acting
came and it was really hard and i you
know like
it wasn't the instant gratification i
wasn't that good at it you know it was
like
i couldn't like i would go to you know
work with like my acting coach
and i've had the same guy for 16 years
now and you know i would go to him
and have to stop in the middle because
there's a guy mowing a lawn or there's a
blower or somebody walked by the window
and
i just can't do this i can't do it this
role is not right for me anyway you know
bye whereas now i walk in and we pound
out an audition in no time
and i know what i'm doing and i lines
are easy to remember and
it when it when it clicked for me was
when i realized
how do i do me like on stage like what
works with me on stage and that's
this kind of guy that seems sincere
delivering lines that really
are pretty stupid you know and
how do i bring that to this yeah i think
aziz actually said that to me once aziz
told me like this is like right after he
was he got parks and rec he was like
just go in there in every line this is
obviously for comedy auditions he's like
i pretend every line i'm on stage
like i just say it if i was on stage i
always say when i'm doing an audition i
always say
a tip for doing auditions is act like
you're actually filming the show right
then and there
like this is yeah you're filming it
right now you know
dude the audition process is so bananas
you know what i mean
like it's especially now with these like
so can you send us a self
tape and all this you just go what
unless it's some meaty
dialogue where you can go i can really
delve into this and show them
something usually it's not that so you
just kind of go
what are you seeing in these dumb this
dumb
two-line whatever this is that you can't
decide
i think he can do it we like how he
looks or we like that you know
or i rather than the director producer
get on and let's have a conversation
like this
let's talk about the role let's talk
about what it means and it's like
i just i don't know you know what i mean
like
yeah i i i mean i like ideally like
right now i'm in vancouver
and and um i'm gonna i'm in a
two-week quarantine and i'm gonna shoot
a movie and uh
i just got it offered and i was like
well this would be great if i could just
get this all the time
yeah because and it's you know that's
that's the
sometimes the bonus that we have as
comedians is people
see us and they just think that's what i
want i see what i see what he is
and that's it you know and that's this
is not like i'm doing a huge movie that
i got offered like the role of batman or
something but
you know it's but even still let's say
you did get offered batman
i would think that you would have gotten
offered batman for more than just
you know you had like they sent a scene
with you and bane no they would want to
be like well let's see what he looks
like in the suit
is he in shape is he like does he have
charisma this way it's like
are you going to see i just sometimes i
just wonder like
is it is is it the auditions i mean i
get with somebody new
who's never done anything but at a
certain point you've been in a
business long enough where they can go
well you know what we've seen him on
this this this
and this i think a combination of all
that you know
if then they could be like all right
we'd like to see you do this scene
because this thing really shows some
stuff but a lot of times it's never a
good scene
no it's and they know within 10 seconds
even before you start reading
you know they know within 10 seconds of
you walking in the room and i've been
told that by some producers and i
believe that i
i've you know when i now that we're
doing the self taping more and i'm
watching my tapes more
i can be like oh yeah in the like the
beginning of this tape
i am confident and i'm aware
and i'm ready and i do it and that's all
they need to see yeah
well you know i've been a part of have
you ever been a part of the casting
process
yes i've had to be the guy where
they had like six girls come in and read
with me
[Music]
and like six guys that were supposed to
be my best friend
see i okay i've experienced that too uh
uh i well it was it was gonna be this
dramatic thing and uh
you know the people coming i learned a
lot from being on the other side of that
yeah you know because one of the things
was what you're saying is like i
remember this
thinking oh that guy's good but he's
just not prepared and i thought to
myself like it really was distracting
that he didn't know the lines
you know then another guy was like oh he
was good but and i thought oh
i got to remember this when i'm on the
other side of this
you know but otherwise too is like i
felt like the casting person they had
their favorite they wanted this one
person
and they were pushing that agenda
you know and i thought oh man there's so
much more to this than just like
as an actor you think i gave the best
performance
so i should get the part and i'm looking
at this now and i'm realizing oh man
this is a whole
there's a whole plethora and nuance to
this audition process that you know you
just got to go in and do your best and
just hope for the best
yeah the the i remember one of the
people that auditioned
uh for to be like my friend in this
movie
he walked in and took his shoes off he
was like barefoot
and halfway through the scenes he would
trail off and not even end them
really and it was
like i found out that he was with my my
same agent afterwards and i called my
agent and i'm like listen
he needs to know a couple things two he
needs to learn his lines and finish
scenes
but don't take your shoes off man it's
just not a good look like no one thinks
you're matthew mcconaughey
no one thinks you're like [__]
getting grounded in the room like
they don't want to see that they don't
want to see your feet yeah
they don't want to unless it's like
unless it actually serves the scene
you know like if unless it says you know
on the beach
so and so comes out barefoot and you
know i know what you mean some people
are just artsy fartsy man
do do you consider yourself artsy fartsy
because you know what without talk
without having like in-depth
conversations with you just seeing you
from a distance
i would think you were artsy fartsy
yeah it can be a little artsy fartsy for
sure
maybe more on the fartsy side but um
i uh i do take take it serious you know
like
when i'm acting on set though i'm not
like a method guy but i do
take space and i do tell people what i
need what i require to be able to
produce what i'm doing like to be in the
right mindset and that means like
don't ever try and show me footage or
playback i just i won't look at it
ever really why is that i don't want to
see me
i don't want to see what who i know is
me
doing this character i just want to do
it
i don't want to have any conception of
what i look like how i'm walking
if i don't like the way that i'm
standing or that i'm leaning
i don't want any of that um
because it just brings me back to me you
know and i'm really fighting everything
i have
right now to not to be the this version
of myself essentially but like you know
the
so yeah i do have like my process and
things but i also know like when you
walk into an audition you want to
present yourself as easy to work with
and like not a problem yeah i'm sure you
can be artsy fartsy and like
talk a little bit and whatever but you
know
[__] taking your shoes off and saying
like i just want to be grounded for this
it's like they don't know
yeah you don't want that i think there's
a fine line about i think what we're
talking about is like professionalism
because when i say archie fartsy i don't
mean it in a negative way even though it
can be taken
that way you know yeah there's a certain
like you know
again like my experience working on them
dying up here working with these like
you know melissa leo she's an academy
award-winning actress
you know what i mean yeah and then you
know so and then me like
you know her coming and tapping me on
the shoulder and giving me some tip
you know her saying to me like you know
something i just realized oh this is
how you're doing this is you're coming
at this in a whole
way that i've never thought about coming
at it before not to say that my process
is bad or her process is the right way
but it does you know there is these
different approaches that people have
and
and i do find that the commit i do find
that comedians have
a more i want to say grounded laid-back
approach i find
just because we don't even realize how
much acting we're doing anyway
even when we get on stage yeah i
i had one job where i learned a couple
things amy poehler
um was producing it and i i used to like
go back to video village just to like
not even to watch but you know this was
when i would watch myself but also just
like to in a video village if anyone
doesn't know it's like we're
all everyone's watching the director and
the producers and
they've got screens in there and then
they they talk amongst themselves
between takes and that's when
the notes come from and i would go back
there and amy pulled me aside and it was
all based out of insecurity
you know and she goes never come never
ever again come back here
you are an actor you stay over there and
you keep doing what you're doing
if somebody here has something to say to
you they will come and say it
if you come back here you're showing
that you're wanting to hear something
they're going to maybe make up notes at
that point because you're just there
it's easy to do
but you need to be confident over there
not caring and not looking to them for
answers
you know what you know what's crazy
about this right now is i
actually feel the complete opposite of
this and i and i got this from what
i was i i did work with adam sandler
you know and we did we you know we did
this murder mystery
and so we had this long walk and talk
you know we're walking from way down the
street and we it's a long walk and talk
right
and yeah and then he goes over to the
villa village to look at it because you
know he's
whatever you know and i went too and i'm
looking and i thought i saw and i was
like
ooh i'm doing a weird walk let me let me
let me
fix that you know or like i'm doing
something with my hands and i'm like oh
i'm not aware of certain things
and that actually helped me so i i yeah
i actually got something out of
looking at and being like okay boom i
like that let me let me do it like this
so it's interesting this perspective
that you're you're telling me about
because i never even thought of it like
that
i don't even think i'm going over there
because of insecurity or anything just
more like
i want to get the best out of my
performance so let me look at it you
know yeah yeah
and i i think that a lot of people get
help that and sometimes if they're like
listen i don't want you to watch
yourself i just want you to see what it
looks like so you know
where you are and i'll be like okay yeah
just show me it show it to me like show
me the frame
and but i i
i know i'm aware of my hands and stuff
so much that like
i can like i'll realize that i'll do a
take and i'll be like why the [__] was i
doing this
yeah i know what you mean like why was i
like telling somebody like you know and
it's like oh just
stop man like [__] stop itching your
nose and like scratching yourself like
you know when i do this so funny when i
first started first started acting like
first job i remember workaholics i i i
you know
i was doing these and then yeah yeah
yeah you know what i mean like
i was like oh i have to act with every
part of my body you know and then
yeah it's like hey man it's like no do
you say do you wave at somebody when
they're standing right in front of you
and say
hey man yeah no i guess they don't do
that
it's like you need some sort of like
activity i found i don't wanna i
just you know i'm dying up here i was
like i was smoking a lot and i realized
oh this is actually a great
thing it's a great like it really keeps
you like doing something
you know you know what i mean so it's
like i know what you're saying man i
i was never just being aware of yourself
is important i mean just
knowing you're something you when you
start doing this more and if you do
kind of occasionally look at yourself
could you watch the shows after
will you watch a movie you're in can you
watch it yeah
yeah yeah okay that's good because some
people are like you don't want to watch
it
ever they're like i did it it's done i'm
done with that i'm moving on yeah
i like to watch it with somebody like
there's like three people that i would
watch something with that i'm in
well and and it's people that know
how it goes people that know like
silence is a thing and it's not to be
awkward it's just
quiet you want to hear the words it's
like i don't know if you've ever
like gone into the studio with a
musician and they like wanted to play
you a track
and you don't [__] talk you don't
move you don't make noise you sit back
and you hear it for three and a half
minutes or however long it is
and then you discuss if you say one word
you're distracting from
the the sound and they're like you just
miss one [__] guitar riff that i
yeah you needed to hear that yeah yeah
yeah you know yeah yeah so
and also there's just people i trust
that'll be like you did great man
this is why and and or be like that's
you know
not that many people are going to see it
you're fine
[Laughter]
i find myself able to look at myself
and and and kind of
divorce myself of like that that's me
you know i actually oh really yeah i
actually really enjoy
like i watch and i go oh this guy oh
that guy oh that wasn't
i really can look at it like that it's
been a strange thing for me it's like
that's
that's why it's really good like when
you did this movie um
the right one you're dressed up in so
many different
outfits and costumes like didn't so when
you look at it does that help you
like to like you know oh that's not nick
that's
something yeah well especially when i
was dressed as a woman
for part of it i don't know if you saw
that part
it's uh you know i go and perform a song
at like uh on stage dressed as a woman
you know and and i'm like doing a
different kind of talk i'm not like
trying to talk like a woman but it's
just a different
speech and you know it's like obvious a
guy dressed as a woman
but i i remember like looking in the
mirror and like kind of twirling my hair
and like
you know i i found that you know and
that
that costume that costume really helped
me find that
yeah there's nothing like dress up dress
up really does help you
you know really lose yourself and be
like let me let me do something i've
never done i can't do as
eric i can't do this as nick i wouldn't
you know what i mean then you go oh yeah
it's great i could do it like this with
this uh
with with this thing um you know you you
you play music yourself uh you know
you're a music you're a musician i know
you can see
yeah you do too don't you not really i
just sing but i don't play an instrument
yeah i've heard you sing yeah you know
but it's like have you ever
did was there ever a time when you
thought oh man i want to be bruce
springsteen
or like you know what i mean still
i mean you know i i um
god i love music so much and i know
that's not like an original
feeling but it my whole life it's just
been a source of
stepping out of myself and um
that's what i love about my stand up
like i can express
i feel like i'm playing i'm a i feel
like i'm a musician the way that i do my
stand-up right right
in the sense that like when i'm doing an
hour i've constructed it in a way
that is up and down and it feels like a
concert or something you know it's like
fun yes yes lead to be
to be like a heartthrob lead singer that
has like you know like really putting
his heart out there and [__] like god
that
be amazing i just can't i can't write
that way
do you think do you take myself
seriously
do you okay so i was going to say
because do you really think it's the
writing or do you think it's more about
how a person feels about
themselves as a performer yeah like
yeah because i'll write and i've i've
written a few songs and
you know i'm right now i'm actually
writing probably more music than i've
ever written and it's
you know it's like you know my voice
comes through in it in a way
to where it's like oh the wittiness you
know like like when you listen to people
that i idolize like john
prine or you know these artists where
the lyrics are jokes i mean they're
funny they're so funny and grounded and
and you just hear it and you're like
that's that you hear his voice it's like
reading hunter s thompson you know
his voice you read it that sentence
looks it's seven words but it looks like
hunter s thompson
you know is there a feeling that you
have that you're not good enough to be
a musician artist like that do you feel
that or do you or
oh yeah i feel like i'm a joke as a
musician but it's
you know i think everyone feels that way
like it's something that's so funny like
i still feel that way about being a
comedian sometimes it's like wait how
did i get here
well you know some people consider me a
pro weird
you know it's funny you say that because
there's another guy in the
comic who does music and i i've always
had these in-depth talks with him about
this where i said man you shouldn't be
at the comedy club you should be at the
roxy
you should be doing what you're doing at
the roxy not at the comedy club because
at the comedy club what you're doing is
you you don't have respect for your
musical art that's why you're at the
comedy club as opposed to being at
some place where it's music because you
don't think that music is good enough
for that place
so then there but this is different from
comedy you know it's it's uh you know
so we got into you know a whole thing
about that so i feel about it so i was
curious to hear
because how you're talking about this
you're
i feel like you could be a heartthrob uh
musician
you know i don't know why you don't
think that because it's because with
this movie the right one
my first thought from the trailer was oh
you're being a leading man and you
looked like a leading man
oh well thank you yeah that's you know
that's the makeup
you know what it is it's just like you
know it's like i don't know why
i don't know why getting into comedy is
so so like
attached like with like an umbilical
cord to
the core of our insecurities
it's it's it's what keeps me on stage
really you know
i i don't have insecurity anymore that
i'm going to fail now my only insecurity
is that i'm a joke
you know it's like i know what you mean
at a certain point you can't even say
you can't even say you're a failure when
you've been in the business for so long
so then
even to yourself you can't even
rationalize it you know so then we
we go to these other things it's more
nuanced in our head
and i know that there's still some bombs
ahead of me in front of audiences
but that i don't even [__] care man
like
literally like let me piss myself on
stage i
like i i don't care i'll find a way out
of it
and like that's my resourceful like you
know like
i find a way out of bombing we that's
how we do it we don't we're like
you can't kill us yeah on stage
we can we're gonna survive the first
moment
the first time early on in my career
that
that i that i bombed really bad
and it didn't matter to me was the
moment i knew that i was gonna be able
to make it
yeah because it's like because then it
became like i always have like a
different point of emphasis now
so even if i could let's say if you say
you if you wrote a new song
joe a joke with you know you might be
able to go on stage and be like i need
to just work on this
and whatever else happens i don't care
as long as
that moment is successful because that's
what i sometimes i go on stage like that
i go i have this new thought i want to
work on and everything else i'm just
like all right i'll just go into other
you know
but it's like yeah at that point of
evidence and i'm not really caring about
oh you know then it becomes different
when you're like on the road and it's
like
nick thune up on this thing and then
it's like oh man i'm putting on a show
right now and i have an obligation to
this crowd and it
becomes you know you know how it all
becomes different in your head and
yeah you know you know what but you know
what our real obligation to that crowd
is
is to be there like the musician that i
i toured with this guy named damian
jurado
who's really just a prolific songwriter
he
he told me that he goes on stage and he
gives them
the opportunity to watch what he would
do
alone at his house he lets them have
that
i like that he lets them have it like
what what a great thing to give them
and that's what i do i started taking
that on stage with me like
you know what i'm not here to fulfill
whatever twenty dollars these people
spent on a ticket and feel like i gave
them twenty dollars worth
they paid twenty dollars to watch me do
this and i'm going to do what i want to
do
that's what they're paying for well i
think that's great i really that's
that's actually a great gem that
that really has like really resonates
with me right now
because i find that doing podcasting um
i find that i
probably have more my given more of my
true self
to my audience than i have on stage
as a comedian trying to write jokes and
craft all these things and so
i totally can see why you know i see why
podcasting is popular especially with
you know because of people's personality
you can't after a while you can't
hide who you are this is me you know who
you know what i mean and so
all these things are going to come
through all these things are gonna come
through and i think that it is a
um a nice thing to try to take down on
stage
or in your performance no matter where
you are so yeah that that's uh
that's a joke i remember you know the
concept of podcast
and like your life i remember i was in
shooting something in chicago and pete
pete holmes came he was like coming
through and doing like two shows at like
the lincoln lodge at the time or
something
and he was like yeah come on down do a
set and i was like i need it thank you
you know and
go and then i watch his whole set and i
mean he's like his his podcast has just
become like really
popular and everyone there is just like
so
excited to watch him you know and he had
a great set
and afterwards we're hanging out and
some guy walks up to him and he's like
hey man i uh you know and pete's not shy
about his like his actual life
but the guy goes hey man you know that
guy that your wife cheated on you with i
went to high school with him
and i'm i'm looking at pete like see and
that's why i'll never do it
yeah yeah i never i never need anyone
knowing that much about me
you're like that's none of your business
that you know pete puts it all out there
which is i mean he did it in his show i
mean it's his whole show is based on
that but like
it was so funny it was like man what a
this what a thing to say
i've you know what i've experienced what
you're saying right now because
i was doing i'm doing i was doing a
movie in boston and eric andre
was in town playing some theater gig you
know
and he hits me up he's like you do come
on down and do a set you know what i
mean
and uh i get there in this pack theater
and like i don't i don't even know eric
andre has
an audience like this like you know what
i mean i didn't even know that yeah you
know what i mean
and and this is what we were talking
about earlier about knowing your niche
like having your like whoever you are he
has
it he he has his group you know
and i went on stage and it was like of
course because it's like this age group
they're like
oh [__] it's montage from workaholic you
know what i mean it's like
i'm this weird attraction now and i was
like oh wow this feels great
you know yeah like this feels better
than like
just it just there was something about
it and and so i guess
now i'm i from hearing you talk about it
now i'm uh i'm actually connecting the
dots of what that
really is it's when your audience really
they feel like
they really know who you are and they
appreciate it and they just want to see
that
yeah and i've i've revealed who i
am through podcasts like that aren't
mine you know like doing marin and doing
like
like certain podcasts where people like
you know really gotten into like
oh yeah you were in rehab or you got
arrested and you did you know like it's
like yep
uh-huh yeah we have the judge from your
trial he's here right now come on
but you know and that's so i i do like
people at least knowing like oh this is
a troubled man who's really trying to do
right you know that's nice
yeah but i think that if we're being
honest we we don't mind
sharing that but what we don't want to
do is discuss it with every individual
that comes to us on the street
like that's the thing that we don't want
and that's just like they wouldn't want
it just like they wouldn't want that
either but
i think there is something about this
format where people think like oh man i
really know that guy now
let me get over there and say hey man
you know i was in rehab too
and there's a part of you that wants to
be like oh that's good man i'm glad
you're doing well
but it's like i don't necessarily want
to go into depth with you about
everything that
you know that you've been touched by and
all that kind of stuff because it's like
i'm just i'm trying to get this subway
sandwich i'm next in line
you know it's like somebody they're like
oh but hold on
you mentioned this chicken that you made
on your podcast and
i've done that but if you add beats and
you're like okay yeah yeah
beats great
you know it's like all you want people
to do is like just you know
it's like they're people do take
ownership of
any any performer they do they just
really no matter who it is
even if they're not on a podcast even if
they even haven't been personal there's
a certain level of like you see them in
a restaurant and you just want to be
like
oh man i don't want to be this guy i
always stop him and go
yes you do yeah yeah you
you're being that guy you're being that
guy just own it my whole thing is like i
just want you to own it right now just
own that you're being that guy and i'll
do whatever you want right now
remember that time you said you came
blood my brother did that
you're like no i'm actually talking to
the waiter right now
you know i'm on one knee i'm trying to
propose to my uh my girl right here
we're trying to be
you know what i mean but thank you for
uh this experience you know
so but seriously if anybody out there
has come blood please talk to me
ugh that would be that's the night as
you get older those are the kind of
things you start to worry about
no i that did happen to me when i was
like 30. oh wow
it was so weird yeah i went to the
doctor
and i like went to a urologist like so
you're like sitting in his office you
know across the desk room and he's like
okay so you came blood
have you talked to anybody about it and
i've realized that he has no [__]
idea what's going on
he doesn't know why it came blood he's
not not dealt with that
well you could ask a lot of questions it
could be like do you jam things in your
hole
do you like you know yeah you know what
i mean it could have been a number
that's scary though when you go to the
doctor and then you're there for
whatever it is and then they're looking
at you like
we'll have what do you think it is like
[__] i'm here for you
like this he's googling blood and [__]
i know you'd be like wait a minute
you're on webmd
it's like i was i was told never trust
webmd
we go to the same web doctor you know
what i do like about this conversation
and i hate that i'm even bringing this
up in the conversation because i've had
so many kind of because like right now
in the world right now you you call
somebody and you go
hey man how you doing and they're like
what do you mean how i'm doing i'm doing
the same as you
i'm [__] stuck at home and i hate
covid but have you been doing in kovit
yeah i've been you know i've been uh
doing great you know it's like i haven't
worked i've had like three stand-up gigs
that
you know like uh two private parties
um you know like in the hollywood hills
for some producers or something
right and then i did a i did like an
online um
zoom gig for a company which here's the
here's the great thing is that they
asked me to roast them which you know
i'm known for
and
no that's one of those that's one of
those because you're a comic oh it means
you talk [__] to people right like
that's them not knowing anything about
you yeah
and they're like and here's they go
here's here's here's our four um
executives these four white dudes like
just out of like a frat that started a
company together
they're like you know here's the list of
things and like one of them it's like
matt's a total numbers guy
he loves numbers and i'm like okay and
like
jason pees all the time like during
meetings he has to get up and pee
i'm like oh jesus and then there's this
whole list of things it's like don't
talk about race
gender politics like all these things
so my first joke was like you know they
want me to roast them
and they said that i can't touch on race
or
gender which obviously they also didn't
touch on when they
chose who were the executives were for
this company
which is these four white guys and dude
i got
[__] i've never like done a corporate
gig and got messages like but
i was getting messages on instagram like
because there was like 500 employees
kind of everywhere
they were like i love it right dude one
guy sent me like a
black fist
and he was like dude someone needed to
say it and i was like whoa
dude you know what's funny is like they
don't even know that in our mind
we're just making fun of this
nonsense restrictions and stuff that
they're doing
but what we don't even realize is that
really taps into
the psyche of how people feel about the
whole thing in general
i've experienced that same thing man
will you just go what are you talking
about what do you mean i can't talk
about
you you know that you just you hit on
something yeah
my biggest frustration when people put
on a comedy show they just think
all you need is a mic and sound and
everything will be fine
you know you know it's like you you know
and then you're in like some
conference room of like some weird
building and you just go this is not
conducive to like a comedy
a comedy show like what are you guys
talking about
well i and i can understand like i i did
a show
where i was in a coffee shop and it was
like during the
it was like at five it was still like
light outside you know
and um there's like three comedians and
there's like three people in the coffee
shop an employee
and somebody walk and i'm no one even
gives a [__] what i'm doing
you know and then somebody walks in and
i realize oh this person has no idea
that this is a comedy show
love that so so they walk in and i go
and that's why i think it's great you
know that they hire employees that
openly have aids and
open sores and they're back there behind
the counter you know and they can just
touch everybody and
and they they like asked me to leave and
they said i could never come back and i
was like you know what that makes sense
yeah that makes sense that i stepped
over the line on that one
okay but like saying i can't touch on
race or gender it's like
what then what man sometimes it's just
that they just have i just think that
there's like a general
lack of understanding of like the comedy
process
so i was doing a show for a homeless
shelter in la
it's a cup you know so they're having
santa monica no
it was for downtown and they're having
this sort of swanky kind of
event for people to you know you know
and so like it's like two comics go
three comics go up
and then the president of the company
goes up and he's
he said he they go well eric before you
the this guy's gonna go up and talk
about
you know the homeless shelter you want
to talk this guy is going in about how
bad the homeless problem is he's going
in about
you know and then they bring up an ex
someone who
was homeless at one time was on drugs
has gone through all the stuff
he comes up and talks and then after
that they're like
and now our headliner eric griffin oh
god so i go up and i say to them
i say to them uh well actually before me
it's going to be
kids with aids in wheelchairs let's
bring them out you know
and then
and so then i think they got it because
then everybody laughed like oh yeah that
was kind of like
not in the in the yeah probably
shouldn't have done it in that order
yeah and that's you know uh they're
actually gonna do a quick funeral
procession
here and then i'm gonna go on yeah
probably
yeah you do you just kind of go like
what are you talking about what what why
what what are you saying right now i
hate the idea listen
i hate the idea that you know we're just
complete monsters like that's kind of
when they come to you and they say
things like you know
hey can we not talk about this this this
and this
as if you're just going to come out
there and be like you know
[__] you know black women's son like
you know you know it's like no no man
there's it's nuanced you if you're
saying to me don't be offensive
or let please you know but don't tell me
a specific things i can't talk about
because there still is a way to talk
about that that i'm gonna make you laugh
and when you tell a comic that kind of
stuff the first thing we're gonna do is
challenge their idea of what they think
is right and wrong
and that's what you did with those
people right there i mean that's the
challenge like it's almost like
oh thank you for telling me that because
guess what
i know and it's like and now because i
did that they're gonna have to be
even more upfront with people like and
do not
when you see this list still don't say
anything
please don't bring up the fact that
we're actually not following the thing
that we're saying that we're going to
follow
okay go yeah you know it's like but you
know what the the
the other side of that is they're
obviously is a desire
and an urge in all of us in all walks of
society
to laugh and to make fun of ourselves i
think that when a company like that
comes to you and says hey can you come
do this it's because they're going
[__] we are taking ourselves way too
serious can you please come enlighten
the mood
you know yeah make fun of us yeah please
make fun of us you know and
but you're just kind of like okay i
don't know you to make fun of you
you know yeah humanize you like what do
you think i'm going to be like oh he was
he was a nebraska husker but we all know
what the huskers are like
i know i'm right right i did i did a
zoom show like about a month ago
for this like tech it was for this not
spacex
but they were like they're a part of
spacex but they're like the people that
make the parts for the space you know
and so like the the ceos they're all
zoomed in and there's screens all over
me you know there's
there's this company that does it they
have all these screens so you could see
everybody you know
and the ceo of the company you know he's
there and it's like
he clearly has a better place than
everybody you know what i mean
so i just made fun of him that way i was
like dude do you got to have the hundred
thousand dollar painting behind you with
all your employees
here you know and you can just see how
the employees they love that kind of
stuff they're like
you know but i can see that guy was just
kind of like okay
yeah no you know you know and the thing
about the guy
that they said um the only people i
could see when i did that show were the
four executives
like because they didn't have it like i
could like i couldn't see anyone else
right
and there was no sound so like i never
heard a noise from the audience because
it was muted and
but the guy that they said that pees a
lot in meetings
i go and you know jason i know they
wrote down here he does get up and pee a
lot in the meetings and
you know i wanted to find out more about
where that came from and i talked to
jason's mom and diane was so sweet
you know she had nothing but great
things to say and she was so proud
because i guess jason is
just last night had his 37th dry night
in a row
and you know we're so happy that he's
not wet in the bed like he was just
38 days ago you know and and again they
were just like no don't do it that way
don't don't like make it seem like
jason's wedding the bed i'm like well
then what the [__]
yeah yeah i'm not a roast guy yeah or
even still it's like you're not like why
don't you just do it
you know like you know what i mean like
why don't you just why don't you guys
just do it like what do you want from me
you know what i mean that's the strange
that's such a oh
my god it's just such a strange
experience like what p
what we've got what we go through just
to do this strange thing called comedy
you know what i mean yeah and there was
one of them that was like oh
jason or whatever has like he's known
for his hair he's got great hair
and i was like that's so great that he's
known for something that
just doesn't matter you know it and i
know that he shows up every day with
that hair thinking i'm better than you
but
he's not i mean it's not even that great
like it's not good you know
and then they're like no don't actually
make fun of us
especially within the only ones on the
screen because it's like
and then everybody at home everybody at
home was like this this is [__]
awesome
he's telling him that's the thing that
like that's the
that's the interesting that's the best
part about it because those people at
home are loving that i've i've seen that
i mean
you know last one is like i i was in la
jolla comedy store
and it was a private gig and then like i
didn't realize this but there was like
these two there was a couple in the
front row
and they were being so obnoxious you
know like they were being obnoxious in a
way like the
the the wife's interrupting me you know
and i'm like what
and then i said to them i was like oh i
get it you guys must run this company
because you think that you can say and
do whatever you want oh yeah you know
and the whole place visibly shift like
you like it like you can see the whole
room go like this okay wow
you know what i mean you know yeah
then i picked up on it i was like and
then you know you know what comics
we like to triple down on [__] yeah
oh my god yeah so i'm doubling down on
it i'm like letting them know like oh
listen i don't actually work for you
so let me let you know that i'm sure
this annoys the [__] out of
all your employees right now you know
it's like i think oh this is
cause i'm giving what they what these
people don't realize they put on this
event
this is the thing that really is going
to help the morale
of your of the whole the whole place the
whole place
needs to know that that they need to
hear someone telling you
sometimes you're a piece of [__] boss
you know i have a i have a bit where i
talk it's like a story of this
one-armed lady that um i had an
interaction with at an airport
once you know and the reveal of her
having one arm and kind of the whole
part
about the story and i was touring and i
had a girlfriend that was with me for a
few days
and she comes backstage and she goes
there's a guy in the front row with one
arm i just want you to know like you
shouldn't do that
and i was like what do you mean actually
now i'm starting i'm opening with that
yeah yeah she's like what i go yeah this
is it yeah you shouldn't have told me
that
yeah it crushed and it's like you think
that guy's sitting up in the front row
with one arm not thinking i'm gonna talk
about it
yeah yeah you know that's that's that's
everyone else's
guilt that they feel you know yeah it's
that whole thing is like when you do a
joke about some
you do a joke about you do a black joke
and all the white people look at the
black person
that's a real thing it's a real feeling
where it's like no i've there was a guy
in my audience one time that he was
full-on player collegiate you know i'm
talking about he was in the wheelchair
you know
with his people you know and i started
making fun of him
you know and everybody was like tense
you know people got tense but i'm
looking at this guy and he's just like
i'm probably going to kill him because
he's laughing so hard you know what i
mean
you know yeah cause it's like i said
then i made fun of the crowd i was like
oh should this guy not feel normal
should he not get like
oh because you guys want to feel better
about your yourselves that you guys have
all your limbs and you can walk
so you don't want to think you know and
then it turned into like you know and
then the person that the the
was with she came to me and she was like
you know
crying because she was like thank you so
much
for making him feel like he's a part of
this
you know and i think that's what people
forget you know that everyone wants to
feel a part
of the joke yeah and if you're if you're
if you're
putting the focus on somebody and you're
not
like you know if they didn't [__]
heckle or do something dumb
and you're just drawing attention to
them you're not going to tear them down
unless you're an [__] and a [__]
shitty comedian exactly
like we don't tear we're not there to
tear them down we're there to bring
light and
show you know like i love a good
wheelchair joke
and then and then a person in a
wheelchair rolls up to you afterwards
like
you're they they're like oh my god can
we take a picture can we do this thing
and it's like
that's when you go i won this moment
yeah you know i have some really great
blind jokes
that um i've had like a couple people
come up to me afterwards and uh like i
have
like just like and i and i throw them in
sporadically like i bcc
stevie wonder and all my emails that
kind of stuff and
uh and it's they love it so much and i
and if i do like an actual chunk of
blind stuff
i have about two three minutes right and
people get [__] worried yeah the only
time that there's ever been blind people
on my show they've
like they've wanted to meet me and take
a photo with me yeah that's it's a weird
it's a weird uh
thing when like whatever going on
whatever sort of like
feeling of sensitivity that's going on
in the uh in the society
it's weird how it sort of trickles into
the club where
it cannot live like that virus that
comes into a comedy club cannot survive
there
because yeah you know because we will it
just there's nothing for it to feed on
here
that it's just gonna kill the whole
thing you know what i mean
well listen man i don't want to keep you
too much longer here
um yeah well thank you for having me i
really appreciate having this car
you know it's like this is probably the
longest we've ever talked to each other
in our whole lives and it just makes me
feel like um
it's like damn you know i gotta read i
got to reach out to people like
yourselves
more often yeah and be like hey man
we've done green blots
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's true we've
been you know we've been but you know
it's one of those things where it's like
oh okay this is cool i mean
and this is what i love about what we do
i do love about what we do the kind of
kindred spirit
of like you know being a performer and
like because it's only only other
performers can truly understand
the the the weirdness that goes on in
our head and
listen i appreciate you being on um i
like i said i started watching the movie
it's very enjoyable i think you're doing
a great job i
i i like i said when i saw it my first
thought even from watching the trailer
was like
look at nick doing that leading man
stuff you know because i saw it
not you know what i mean it's not like
i'm saying that like look at this clown
you know no i was like oh oh
oh oh oh
[Laughter]
so so uh yeah so make sure an audience
riffing griffin people check that out
i'm gonna have all of nick's links down
below you can find you on all the social
media so they can ask you about your
bloody [__]
and then uh you know what i mean people
please send in pictures of your
it'll be a powerpoint
yeah send presentation in keynote yeah
whatever the new app is now
the powerpoint isn't even a thing what
am i talking about but um but dude
thanks for being on be safe out there
good luck on this new project and i and
i hope to talk to you soon
awesome eric yeah talk to you soon man
take care
all right and we did it
please i hope this worked
all right guys well that was nick thune
and i hope you watched that
make sure you watch the right one check
that movie out when it comes out i think
it's gonna be streaming
probably gonna be out in uh i think it's
on hulu actually um but
you know check the movie out and once
again thanks for watching reference
griffin
you know i'm going to be i'm streaming
i'm always on uh twitch i'm twitch daily
at air griffin gaming so make sure you
guys check that out
and i got more guests and more
interviews and more
things uh coming moving forward so make
sure you guys uh look out for that
and thanks again again for watching